en su tercer viaje a África en menos de
seis meses el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de Rusia sergei calificó Su
primera visita oficial a Mali como
histórica y elogió la alianza entre
bamaco y Moscú en la lucha contra una
insurgencia yihadista en la región los
funcionarios malienses entregaron a la
brooff una espada tradicional tuarek
también le dieron la orden Nacional de
Mali
Seguiremos brindando el apoyo necesario
a nuestros amigos no solo en cuestiones
de desarrollo económico y comercial y
asistencia humanitaria sino también para
resolver el problema de aumentar la
capacidad de combate de las fuerzas
malienses capacitar al personal militar
y a los oficiales encargados de hacer
cumplir la ley
desde la expulsión de las fuerzas
francesas el año pasado el líder militar
de Mali el coronel asilo evita ha
buscado fortalecer los lazos con Moscú
la junta gobernante ha traído
helicópteros aviones de combate y
paramilitares rusos es una relación que
ha preocupado occidente que dice que los
agentes rusos son mercenarios de Wagner
un grupo militar privado que defiende
los intereses del kremlin y es acusado
de abusar en contra de los Derechos
Humanos alegaciones desestimadas por el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
Mali
ministro al optar por fortalecer la
cooperación con Rusia
contiene Mali también quiere Mostrar y
demostrar que no vamos a seguir
justificándonos por la elección de
nuestros socios Esta es una decisión de
malin una decisión tomada con
responsabilidad
indecisión
el ministro de relaciones exteriores
también confirmó que el coronel goita
asistirá a una Cumbre Rusia África que
se realizará en San Petersburgo en julio
frente a las sanciones occidentales por
la guerra en Ucrania
Moscú Busca expandir su influencia en el
continente africano cortejando a los
líderes algunos de los cuales se han
negado a condenar públicamente la guerra